[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
oh
[Musique]
nous venons d'inaugurer la place
marguerite père est au coeur du plateau
de saclay sur la commune de palaiseau
cet après midi et j'ai été extrêmement
fiers de pouvoir à la dénommée
marguerite perret en l'honneur de cette
grande scientifique cette chimiste
suisse nucléaire qui au début du 20e
siècle a eu de nombreux travaux avec
marie curie avec irène joliot curie et a
été notamment en 1962 la première femme
à entrer à l'académie des sciences
c'était important que sur ce quartier
qui est au coeur de l'innovation
française au coeur de la recherche
française nous mettions à l'honneur des
scientifiques et en particulier des
femmes scientifiques il y a trop peu
dans notre pays deux noms de rues de
noms de places qui sont dénommées après
des femmes est ici à palaiseau et en
particules sur le plateau de saclay
c'était pour nous quelque chose
d'extrêmement important notamment par
rapport aux faits scientifiques qui est
majeure
cette place est un lieu de vie pour le
quartier il y aura évidemment de
nombreux commerces vous voyez derrière
moi une boulangerie un supermarché un
restaurant qui est déjà présent ça sera
aussi la place qui sera en face de la
future gare du métro de la ligne 18
quand il sera là en 2026 mais
régulièrement il y aura beaucoup
d'événementiel qui pourront avoir lieu
ici ça sera vraiment le coeur battant du
quartier
[Musique]